a couple just went viral for bragging
about the dink lifestyle we're dinks
we're going to get asked daily when we
plan on having kids we're dinks of
course we're going to go out to eat
every night after work we're dinks we
don't have to ask our family for
financial help or to watch our kid when
we want to go out we're dinks we're
going to go to Costco and buy all the
snacks in bulk that we want we're dinks
we have disposable income to spend all
whatever we would like and don't have to
spend on a kid weird dings I'm going to
go to Every football game and play 18o
whenever I want we're dinks we're going
to get asked to every single family
event what we're doing with our life I'm
depressed cuz I just watched this video
I'm very sad about the state of our
culture because I just watched that
video I'm frankly not betting on much of
a future for Western Civilization
because I just watched that
video I'm I'm Michael I'm
Michael this new
trend put the dinks aside for a second
this new trend of the the I'm blah blah
blah and blah blah blah blah blah that
I've seen go around the Internet it's
absolutely unbearable and it's
especially unbearable when you're
talking about something like the dinks
because what we're looking at here is
not merely a couple suffering from
infertility who knows maybe they did
suffer for maybe they did really want
kids and now they're just coping and
they're putting on a strong face about
it and trying to promote something that
they don't actually desire that could be
the case many people do
that but what they're at least doing on
the surface is they are saying it is
better to intentionally abstain from
having
kids if you are a married couple and
that is obviously not true that's not
what marriage is for marriage is for
having kids not everyone gets to some
people are infertile it's a a terribly
difficult experience to go
through but that's what it's for you you
can have a good life
without children if you're a married
couple and you're infertile you can be
God Parents you can be very involved in
the lives of your nieces and nephews you
can be very involved in the life of your
community say your church or other Civic
associations you
can if you are single and you're not
going to have kids you can join a
religious order you can consecrate your
singlehood to to God you can do things
for other people with the extra time and
money that you have for not having
kids all of that is
true the one thing that will certainly
not make you happy if you are a married
couple without kids is doing what these
people are
suggesting we're dinks we get to buy a
lot of snacks at Costco I have multiple
children I I can buy the snacks that I
want at Costco Costco is has really
great prices and lots of snacks frankly
you don't even have to pay for the
snacks at Costco because they have so
many free
samples that your children are not
preventing you from buying
Doritos we're dinks we get to go to
dinner every night that's I don't get to
go out to dinner every night that's
true dinner every night at restaurants
gets very boring sometimes it's nice to
sit at home with your family and have
dinner we're dinks I get to go to
football games all the time football
games are you can watch them on TV first
of all I'm not a huge football guy but
you can watch them on TV it's okay and
you can take your kids to football games
and that's more enjoyable than just
going
alone we're dink so I get to go golfing
whenever I want yeah golf is guys don't
I think it was Shaw who said that hell
is the place where you have nothing to
do but amuse yourself right now go to
jus.com
nsyt letter y letter T I have got a
Christmas gift idea that is sure to make
you the hero of the season and we all
know the holiday season can be a little
bit hectic the shopping the cooking the
long list of things to do Fe not because
I've discovered a gift that is both
thoughtful and transformative the gift
of Jus cell skincare from now until
Christmas Jus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at jus.com letter y letter
T treat yourself and your loved ones to
the absolute best skincare in the world
those troubling forehead wrinkles Fine
Lines skin red andness sagging jawline
will disappear right before your eyes
with jus cell's most popular collection
Jus cell promises immediate effects you
will see results in less than 12 hours
guaranteed or your money back their
products use the best stuff out there on
the market the prices are incredibly
competitive and in fact they will give
you special holiday discounts because
they know even if they lose money on
this order they know that you are going
to keep coming back that is how good it
is go to Jus cell.com
nsyt get this incredible holiday
discount today every order is instantly
upgraded to free express shipping genu
cell.com why it today there are plenty
of things I like to do on my own I like
to smoke cigars I like to read books I
like to strum my ukulele I even like to
paint I'm not a good painter but I like
painting I like to go on walks I like to
do all sorts of fun
things it gets old it gets old I I know
people who have intentionally not had
children I'm not kidding because they
really like going to
brunch they really like going out to
brunch and they really like traveling
say especially Millennials they love
that brunch has diminishing marginal
Returns on happiness even traveling has
diminishing I love traveling I've
traveled extensively it even that has
diminishing marginal returns it is true
that when you have kids you will have
less disposable income you will have
less time you'll sleep a lot less you'll
be stressed more in some
cases the Sublimity of children
is is simply Indescribable I would not
be able to do it justice here I remember
I I give you at least one
little sketch to give you a sense of
it my first book with words I guess my
only book with words for now and my
first baby were both due on the same day
couple of years ago and I of course
pushed it to the deadline as did my baby
and so we're sitting in the delivery
room and it's my poor wife just
screaming
you know preparing to give birth and me
fixing the footnotes on my manuscript
before I sent it off to the publisher
and I had really put my heart and soul
into this book spent a long time writing
it put put my back into it and I finally
sent it off my wife had even said she
goes you know I'm giving birth to my
baby you're giving birth to your baby
and I finally sent off the manuscript of
something I'd been working on for 18
months longer than my wife had been
working on our baby and then my wife
delivered our son and I realized in that
moment that my book didn't matter at all
it became a number one National
bestseller speechless controlling words
controlling MCH you can order it now if
you like I'll thank you very much but
doesn't matter at
all similar to what St Thomas aquinus
said after he had a a mystical Vision at
the end of his life and St Thomas
aquinus the one of the most important
intellectuals ever to walk the
earth wrote the Suma theologia among
many other works was said to be ble to
write multiple books at a
time and he he had a mystical vision and
he said oh all that I have written is so
much straw doesn't none of that matters
brunch doesn't matter football doesn't
matter your snacks at Costco they don't
matter at all when it when it comes to a
much deeper purpose like the deepest
like the purpose of your marriage just
absolute Peak decadence and Hedonism
have I been harsh enough I think I have
I think maybe I have there are things
that the couple can do if they can't
have kids golfing and eating snacks is
not among the things that will make them
happy boy what a great clip that was now
hey hey hey ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel see you
next time